I was told give up and I have to live
with my red discoloration on half of my
face for the rest of my life and I felt
like I don't want to give up on myself
I'm gonna go out there and find a
solution
my name is Baz Muhammad and I help
people heal from the inside out I am a
micropigmentation specialist I
camouflage all types of scars birthmarks
and burns I implant pigment in scar
tissue to eliminate any discoloration in
the skin when I was 2 years old I was
playing in the kitchen with my brother
and fire started a hot oil ended up
spilling on 50% of my face I ended up
with third-degree burns and I've had
almost a hundred different types of
surgeries and laser treatments and none
of them were successful I went to talk
to my plastic surgeon I asked him what
can I do and he said just take your
money go on a vacation this is the end
for you we can't improve it I said what
about permanent cosmetics can I get my
eyebrows tattooed and he said it's the
worst thing you can do for yourself scar
tissue will never pick up pigment so
that day I decided I'm gonna go and have
my eyebrows tattooed my scar tissue
picked up the pigment
from that moment I thought why not make
skintone pigments and implant that
pigment in the scar tissue to eliminate
the discoloration I started apprenticing
with a permanent makeup artist I learned
everything that I needed to know about
skin I decided to be my first client and
work on my own face I was able to
camouflage all the red discoloration and
I had something that actually worked
originally when I started it I wanted a
solution for myself but from there it
had like a much bigger purpose we have
the clinic in Toronto Canada and we have
the clinic now in Beverly Hills and we
performed this procedure every single
day now we reached a point where Plastic
Surgeons reach out to us they want to
learn more about the procedure we've
performed thousands of procedures in the
last 15 years and its clients they'll
find from all over the world every year
we take on few big cases and we donate
those treatments Adela has a point stain
on her face and she's had so many
different types of treatments and
nothing really has worked for her
very thankful for her because she's
making my dream come true you know I
used to use the heavy makeup to cover
inner layer layer it's a big difference
it used to be four times more great the
best part about this it's seeing people
transform and that's why I'm so grateful
that I never gave up on my journey I was
able to help thousands of people
[Music]